>> Laura: HAVE YOU HEARD OF
A PUSH POLL.
ABSURD PUSH POLL FROM THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS FINDS 57%
OF AMERICANS THINK PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS A RACIST.
THAT INCLUDES MORE THAN 8
OUT OF 10 AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
NEARLY THREE QUARTERS OF
HISPANICS AND NEARLY 50% OF
WHITES.
LET'S BRING IN SOMEONE WHO
KNOW AS LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MEDIA MANIPULATION.
FORMER REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
HERMAN CAIN AND GARLAND
NIXON.
I HAVEN'T SEEN BOTH OF NEW
WAY TOO LONG.
GARLAND, LET'S START WITH
YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK IF THE POLL IS TRUE,
IT'S HIGHLY DEPRESSING TO
ME.
OKAY.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
ECONOMY REALLY IS DOING
BETTER WHY HAVE THE LOWEST
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT IN 17
YEARS.
LOTS OF GOOD INDICATORS,
SLIGHTLY HIGHER GRADUATION
RATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL WHICH
IS GOOD BUT HE HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE FOR 13 MONTHS.
PEOPLE'S WAGES WILL START
GOING UP AND BRING JOBS
BACK.
WHAT ELSE NOT TO LOVE.
>> THAT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
ISSUE HERE AT HAND IS DONALD
TRUMP A RACIST?
PERSONALLY I WOULD SAY THAT
TERM IS FAR TOO RESTRICTIVE
FOR A GUY WHO HAS EXHIBITED
THE LEVEL OF BIGOTRY AS
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK WE HAVE TO USE A
BROADER TERM.
I THINK BIGOTRY WORKS.
WE REMEMBER THE INSULTS TO
THE HANDICAP WITH THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" GUY.
HE SAID THAT A MEXICAN JUDGE
WAS UNABLE TO DISPENSE THEIR
DUTIES.
>> Laura: HE THOUGHT IT WAS
A CONFLICT -- I KNOW IT CAME
OUT THAT WAY.
BUT I HAVE KNOWN HIM FOR 13
YEARS.
I DON'T TOLERATE RACISM.
WOULDN'T BE FRIENDS WITH
SOMEONE WHO IS A RACIST.
I ACTUALLY KNOW HIM.
IS HE NOT A RACIST.
I'M TELLING YOU IT IS
FACTUALLY UNTRUE TO SAY IS
HE A RACIST BECAUSE I KNOW
HIM.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY EXCUSE
YOU CAN SAY I KNOW HIM.
>> Laura: BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
HAVE PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE.
>> I LOOKED INTO HIS SOUL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> I JUST KNOW HIM.
>> LOOK BY WHAT HE SAYS THE
TUNE OF THE FAMOUS COACH
SAYS YOU ARE WHAT YOUR
RECORD SAYS YOU ARE.
>> Laura: GARLAND SAYS HE IS
A RACIST.
>> BIGOT.
>> Laura: NOT ALL
ENCOMPASSING ENOUGH.
GO AHEAD.
>> NOW, MR. NIXON, PLEASE
DON'T TRY TO TALK OVER ME
WHICH IS WHAT LIBERALS DO.
HE IS NOT A RACIST.
AND YOU AND OTHERS ARE
CONCLUDING THAT HE IS A
RACIST.
BASED UPON YOUR SPECULATION
FROM SOME STATEMENTS THAT
WERE MADE.
YOU HAVE NO EVIDENCE, NO
RESULTS THAT SUGGEST THAT
HE'S A RACIST.
SECONDLY, I, LIKE LAURA, I
KNOW MR. TRUMP.
I CAN SPOT RACISM
3,000 MILES AWAY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A RACIST
BONE IN HIS BODY, BASED UPON
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
BUT IN THAT PARTICULAR STUDY
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
REFERENCING, EVERY INCIDENT
IDENTIFIED IS BASED UPON
SPECULATING THAT HE MUST
HAVE BEEN SAYING SOMETHING
RACIST WHEN, IN FACT, HE WAS
NOT SAYING ANYTHING RACIST.
>> WELL, RUBBINGS IT'S 21%
OF REPUBLICANS THINK I IS
RACIST ACCORDING TO THIS
POLL, SHOCKING.
DEMOCRATS 85% HER MAN.
DO YOU BELIEVE 21% OF
REPUBLICANS THINK DONALD
TRUMP IS A RACIST?
I DON'T KNOW WHO THESE
REPUBLICANS ARE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY BELONG
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
TO ME, IT'S CRAZY U THEY CAN
DISAGREE WITH HIS POLICIES
THAT'S FINE OR SAY HE
SHOULDN'T TWEET THAT'S FINE.
>> EXACTLY, DISAGREE WITH
HIS POLICIES, YES.
YOU CAN'T DISAGREE WITH THE
RESULTS.
HERE'S WHY YOU HAVE SUCH A
HIGH NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
BELIEVING THAT HE IS RACIST
AND YOU HAVE A FEW
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE BEING TOLD THIS.
LIBERAL MEDIA AND MANY
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN USING
FALSE RACIST NARRATIVE EVER
SINCE THIS PRESIDENT BECAME
PRESIDENT AND EVEN BEFORE.
AND AS A RESULT, MANY OF
THEM ARE SIMPLY REPEATING
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD.
THIS PRESIDENT IS NOT
RACIST.
>> Laura: GARR
>> Laura: GARLAND, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAS STALLED
THE ADVANCEMENT OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THIS
NEW STUDY THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TIME TO GET INTO, ECONOMIC
INSTITUTE.
WAGES AND UP EMPLOYMENT FROM
16 OF 1968 TO 2017.
WE HAVE TOLERATED MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
AMERICA WHO TAKE JOBS THAT
WORKING POOR, MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
WORKPLACE FOR THE FIRST TIME
USED TO HAVE.
AND A LOT OF THOSE JOBS ARE
GONE NOW.
THOSE ENTRY LEVEL JOBS HURT
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT I
CAME FROM AND A LOT OF
MINORITIES.
AND THEY ARE NOT THERE
ANYMORE.
AND TRUMP IS STANDING
AGAINST.
>> I WOULD SAY MOST OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WOULD STAND
AGAINST YOU FOR THAT REASON.
THAT IS BLACK PEOPLE ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR JOBS PICKING
GRAPES.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR
JOHNS WORKING IN HOTELS.
THEY WANT TO BE LAWYERS AND
DOCTORS AND POLICEMEN.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THEY DO.
I PICKED FRUIT AND DID PAPER
ROUTES AND WORKED IN
RESTAURANTS.
YOU NEVER DID THOSE JOBS?
THOSE JOBS TAUGHT ME A LOT.
>> BLACK AMERICANS WANT THE
SAME JOBS.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY IS NOT
BLAMING THE GUY AT THE
BOTTOM.
THEY ARE BLAMING THE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE THE DECISIONS.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT BLAMING
THEM EITHER.
WE ARE BLAMING GLOBALISTS
KEEPING WAGES LOW.
I'M BLAMING THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO KEEP THE WAGES DOWN.
>> MY POINT IS IF ANYONE WHO
IS CONVINCED BY SOMEONE WHO
HAS MORE MONEY THAN THEY DO
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LESS MONEY THAN THEY DO ARE
THE PROBLEM.
ARE BEING MANIPULATED.
>> HER MAN, LAST WORD, REAL
QUICK.
THE MANIPULATION IS GOING ON
BY LIBERALS AND DEMOCRATS.
I SEE IT EVERY DAY:  I SEE
IT EVERY DAY ON MY RADIO
SHOW.
I'M PART OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
I'M A RADIO TALK SHOW HOST.
I LIKED THAT JOB.
I NEVER DREAMED I WOULD BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT JOB.
DO YOU KNOW HOW I GOT IT?
I WORKED HARD AT IT I GOT IT
THE OLD FASHIONED WAY.
PROBABLY THE WAY YOU GOT
YOURS.
SO, THESE BLANKET STATEMENTS
ABOUT PEOPLE NOT MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY BEING TOLD
SOMETHING ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO
MAKES A LOT OF MONEY, THOSE